[Music]
meet dina karpava
russian champion skier aerospace
engineer
and international property broker
dina has a lucrative new business
selling england to super-rich russians
she is fast-tracking their children into
england's high society
and getting them into our most
prestigious schools
dina has just flown in from moscow she
has a very wealthy russian client who
wants his children to get into a british
public school
our clients do want to go to to top
schools they do want their kids to be
with
best british families and to be friends
with them
there is not one company in russia who
works with top schools or preparing
children to go into top schools
the only choice is is me actually
dina has teamed up with educational
consultant charles bonus
tina hi hi how are you doing how are you
good to see you yeah you too russian
english we haven't arabic english
dina is thinking of sending her clients
children on a bespoke residential course
to introduce them to the english
aristocracy and teach them how to blend
in by giving your child the opportunity
of participating
in an english mentors program you will
have made a real investment
into their future they will be tested
undoubtedly
but they will be uh rewarded for their
efforts
what exactly are they going to do if
they go against the family
for a weekend we've got a number of
tutors who are specialists and preparing
children
from overseas for common entrance then
in the afternoons we'll do some really
fun activities with them
like um they might do a bit of shooting
polo golf tennis or something like that
dina knows there are school agents in
the middle east and asia
doing everything they can to get
children into top schools in the uk
competition is fierce you know there is
no question about it now a lot of
british schools kept the percentage of
the foreign students
you you compete with asian kids
who are you know breed as a race horses
to
to get into the system i think a
critical aims is just to experience
life with an english family really just
seeing how
people live in england didn't run out of
money to fix this one
a dinner it's the rustic look it's a
country farm house
that's why you're in england we're not
in russia understated
and authentically quaint
[Music]
dina son ivan is at one of the top
public schools in england
westminster today he's rowing for his
school
getting a van into westminster wasn't
easy and that's when dina saw a gap
in the market by word of mouth it spread
around immediately that
ivan got to westminster from
moscow without being an english school
and that's how it all started
it's quite a trend now in russia to send
the children to
england a lot of people who can afford
are doing that it's like already
becoming
a your child isn't going there
unfortunately by the time dina gets to
the competition she's missed ivan's race
how did you guys do he's at the finish
line
over there yeah so we completely missed
it
as a child champion skier dina knows
what it's like to be passionate about a
sport
but like her clients she's paying a lot
of money for ivan to be at school here
and academic achievement comes first my
parents always said you know earn your
bread
but using your head you know i always
let yvonne to experience any sport you
know he was skiing and
now he's into rowing well fantastic it's
a big sport in westminster
you know yes but
think about it is that time invested in
you know all these practices two hours
in on a cold river is it really worth it
are you done shall we go i'm freezing
[Music]
mint house in dorset the family seat of
the 12th lord digby
dina has brought her clients 11 year old
son natan
and stepson vasily for an intensive and
expensive course
in making the right impression the
course is run by ex-army officer
nigel haddon payton we've arranged them
to be introduced to the game of polo
it's a very very popular game over here
uh i started when i was actually younger
than them i
but mind you i had a mother who used to
train the rhodesian or the zimbabwean
polity
and she had four sons so she had her an
instant polo team
so i started almost before i could walk
but it was just nothing
yet
[Music]
have you yes uh how much well like three
times in my life
okay and uh nation one time
ten minutes okay so not a lot of
experience on the horse
yeah the polar player needs a decent
strong
knee-length boot and a good sturdy hat
knee pads are very important it is the
fastest ball sport in the world and it
is a full contact sport
and without a decent pair of knee pads
your knees would be in shreds
unfortunately every now and again
you know a player does hurt himself okay
so ready dina has brought ivan along
to show off his polo playing skills at
only 14 ivan is already a product of his
cosmopolitan upbringing
i always consciously mix in culture for
him
so he was in russia his first years and
he was living in the united states
and i thought well british culture is
quite different and it's fantastic too
for him to have it our clients want
to match the culture they don't want to
be viewed as
as new russians or nuvarish exposure to
the best
representatives of this culture and to
the kids of that families
is invaluable this is parsnip this
[Music]
we'll we'll go through that in in just
two seconds
okay perfect turn your horses round but
face the other way
he's out of control yeah no but you're
in control okay so turn paper around
come on you say come on parsnip this way
[Music]
they're hitting the ball well i'm very
impressed
the hardest thing is actually wielding
the mallet and these are argentinian
i got a lot of ones did you
that is a really nice game ivan's
upbringing is very different to that of
dina's
when i was growing up we were not
allowed to even talk to a foreigner
you know that were serious consequences
but i grew up in a closed city located
in the urals
dina's parents were physicists working
for the government
developing top-secret nuclear weapons
the facilities were hidden in the
forests
and the whole town is a separate country
you know you have as
a border and the border is watched 24 7.
despite the lack of freedom life was
good for dina and her family
unlike most russians they were well paid
and had a high standard of living
dina eventually graduated as an
aerospace engineer
but the breakdown of the communist
regime in the early 90s
brought an end to dina's relatively
privileged life
the nightmare started when perestroika
started and the financing was cut off
the nuclear physicist has to go and
plant potatoes because they had to eat
something
all of our salaries stopped i was going
on a subway you know i had
a one-year-old child and thinking oh my
gosh you know
what what are we going to do we sold
everything
we're working for nothing the government
owes us a year's salary
you know giving a little cards that we
can go buy bread
i opened moscow times the classifieds
saw the advertising for office manager
but in three months i transferred to
another
to another company became you know one
of the top brokers and
real estate brokers in in moscow
within a few years dina had moved to new
york
and become a wealthier successful
businesswoman
that's how all the success stories in
russia are
you stumbled on something and you were
not afraid and
you know you talked your way and and
that's how all the fortunes were
were built proper fortunes i am handing
you a gun
is that all right is that safe why
because dina's role as agent to the
russian super rich
comes at a price you know we're rather
expensive
it's funny when families start saying
well why are you charging more than
any other companies immediately i tell
my stuff
in russia those are not our clients if
they start asking about
our fee they don't realize what we do
because the biggest asset that we do is
basically preparing children
gently treat it like your girlfriend
right across that's now they know how to
handle a horse
and a gun natan and vasily should have
no problem joining the english country
set
we've just messed up the bedroom a bit
thrown towels on the floor
messed up the bed um and
i'm just going to run through them how
it should look when they're staying in a
someone's house rather than in a hotel
which i think is what
uh they're probably more used to right
boys
we've messed up your bedroom a bit bed
vastly what do you do our clients come
from all over the world
it's a very big cross-section some of
these children
they they're given far too much when
they're very young
and that of course starts them off on
quite the wrong foot
because they believe they can flick
their fingers and things happen
and one of the things we point out to
them is that one day
you know you may not have this wealth
for a lot of reasons the oil may run out
the gas may run out
and it's a fact of life and after you've
had a bath what's always good
is just to rinse it down the course has
come to an end
the boys have also had intensive
academic tutoring
[Music]
dina carpenter is fast tracking russian
children into england's top public
schools
her own son ivan is a border at
westminster
before she flies home to moscow she
needs to plan when they'll next spend
some precious time together
thank you so any results from
throwing yeah we came on second well it
could have been better but
with other petals poles
what is that
i didn't know the word in english don't
laugh at me
okay i don't know all the words you
should
i should but you know i didn't have a
chance to go to westminster
thank you enjoy your meal thank you so
we need to do this logistics
for easter we've been invited to go
skiing to switzerland or we can go to
united states
i think if you want skiing and you don't
have any rowing commitments
if you email me i have i told you it's
from the yes darling
darling you told me in the passing you
need to email me and tell me
how we're spending your birthday i would
very much like you to fly for three days
to russia
for your birthday i'm not going
oh please don't argue with me
[Music]
dina is meeting natan and vasily and
their father boris
a famous russian businessman
boris has flown in for a whirlwind tour
of schools
and today they're visiting stowe in
buckinghamshire traditionally the
the great schools have have educated a
lot of the ruling
families so that culture is there and
the new russians are doing their very
best to replicate the lifestyles
of the czarist elite and part of that
is is being educated in the west
hello hi welcome to stowe i'm david
fletcher these
families have gone through a great deal
of change from an authoritarian
state to unbridled capitalism and in
some areas decadence
so sending a child to a british police
school is going to give them a sense
that there are some things
some values that transcend materialism
the oligarchs see that this provides
them with an international cosmopolitan
outlook which just doesn't exist in in
russia
so how have you found coming to england
so far
interesting yeah really interesting are
you into sports
i really love football okay do you
support a football team
yeah manchester united i support a
russian football team
yeah chelsea
and so what we're going to do is in a
little while alexia's going to take you
to have a look around the school
he came to us from russia in the sixth
form so we thought it'd be
useful to talk to somebody who's perhaps
doing a similar
sort of journey to you right okay
okay alexi yeah over to you
[Music]
stow was established in the 1920s and
has some high profile former pupils
probably you know richard branson i
think he's a billionaire
actually and well he's a very famous
person
if you've got any questions just ask me
okay just interrupt me whatever whenever
you want
yes question how much you do the lessons
long in here
uh it's around 40 minutes on tuesdays
and
thursdays we've got chapel yes when we
have to come here
and we've seen like different hymns just
try to practice
to improve ourselves
for all the preparation the boys have
had home is still over a thousand miles
away
it just never ceases to amaze me how
brave they are coming to a new country
often speaking in a few words of the
language and then having to adapt
to a very different education system
being away from home
learning the language so it's it's it's
tough what's your name
yeah this is where matron lives nation's
role is very much to
to look after your health for minor
things yeah you're unhappy or you want
to talk about anything
look what i've just found the little
horrors i've just gonna stuck something
on there i think we'll remove that all
these rooms here
uh face south so you get that fantastic
view of the golf course
each student has a laptop in here yeah
everything
if they want to or they have to really
have to have one but of course
you're not allowed to play games this
isn't going to be
a five-star ritz hotel but
at the same time they want that they
don't really want their children
to go from you know a yacht to a villa
from a villa to a private school
which is you know another um another
luxurious
environment they they really want to you
know have their children growing up with
a relative sense of normality as
normal as a boarding school can ever be
this is vaseline hello vassi this is ed
abel smith who's the senior boy
in the house but he's also in charge of
the uh the beagles so he goes hunting
with the beagles
um ev every wednesday yeah
yeah that's standing wow
[Music]
yeah this is the south front
[Music]
it's quite impressive that's where duke
of edinburgh held
his balls
it will cost boris at least sixty
thousand pounds a year for the boys to
attend a boarding school such as stowe
britain's is the most extraordinary
country in a way that we can
integrate people from so many different
ethnic backgrounds and i think public
schools do that
very very well i mean yes they are very
elitist but there's
nothing you can do to stop that i think
they're becoming they're becoming more
elitist
in a positive sense in a way that they
are becoming censors for excellence so
brilliant scholars and children can can
apply that and be given scholarships now
in sense of you know british eating
cucumber sandwiches and being terribly
polite i think it's it's a bit of a myth
and this is this is vasily and the boys
are meeting the headmaster
and it's crucial they make a good
impression hello and where is home in
russia which
cities san pedro
so you're quite interested in politics
and current affairs
and what about russian history no i
studied russian history by myself
really yeah and which which period most
interests you the second world war with
russia
i know loads of stuff i know majorly i
know that
um like the tanks and planes of world
war one and world war ii
these oligarchs are quite dynastic and
the next generation some of these
children will
be controlling tens of thousands of
people who work for them
so an english education that emphasizes
some of the positive aspects of english
culture particularly our
liberal attitudes inventiveness
a sense of enterprise i don't think that
can be a bad thing
i think that britain is going to play
a huge part in the russian future and i
think it's a fantastic thing
because these kids will merge the
cultures they're not going to fight
they wouldn't be fight as as their
fights now and people couldn't connect
they'll just call their body that is in
the cabinet
say hey tony what the heck are you doing
stop it and you're working towards the
common entrance exam
they just entered this system in
september
so even watching their progress from
september
till now is there they're doing they're
doing
really great and i think there would be
we can expect
greater things from them what's next
goodbye it was really nice to meet you
thank you well thank you very much for
taking an interest in the school nathan
okay goodbye okay that's very nice thank
you very much
bye-bye
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
back in london charles is meeting dina
to discuss the boy's progress
dina hey good to see you how are you
so how did you get on at stowe on friday
it was fine um
you know obviously it was first
interview ever but the boys tried their
best they
loved the school today yeah boris liked
the fact that it's located in a tiny
little town how beautiful it is but as
you know for every russian
if it's far from history and far from
london it's such
it's just no for parents who are flying
for a day and a half to see their
children
that's that's the reality that's why you
know harrow and westminster are on top
of everyone's list
since their trip to stowe the boys have
visited various schools around the
country
natan and vasily have been offered a
conditional place
in charter house which is a fantastic
result
keeping in mind that they've just been
in the country for
such a short time so all they need to do
is to work
towards the exams in january and if they
pass the exam
[Music]
you